how you feeling I'm wonderful it's a
long season for you then you throw in
March Madness you got the NBA season you
got to deal with those knuckleheads
Charles and Shaq you know it's a it's a
nice break from that it really is um I
love the college game always love
Madness and to be part of it is a lot of
fun it's a lot of prep a lot of a lot of
a lot of work that you're doing in the
middle of the NBA season to familiarize
yourself with the college kids and the
teams etc um but then when you get to
this point you feel like you know them
all pretty well and so it's a great
weekend but it helps you I would think
that it gives you a little head start
for them getting into the NBA sure that
you're doing you're cramming for a final
exam during March Madness but then it's
going to help you with the draft and
then next season with the NBA but a lot
of that's true it gives you it gives you
a little lead uh lead in and you and you
can remember what these guys did in the
tournament when you see them in the
league but uh tomorrow would I don't
know how you feel about it but tomorrow
to me is one of the great days if you're
looking at the sports calendar you got a
circle that I mean it's it is such a fun
atmosphere all the colors all the
schools everybody on the street and I
just I just love that day and then to
have those two games and and everything
that goes with it whether that's
celebrating or trying to sell your
tickets to somebody who wants to go to
Monday night let me give you the full
introduction for Ernie Johnson he's
hosting the studio coverage of the Final
Four the semies and of course the title
game on TBS that'll be tomorrow and
Monday for the first time in the 78 year
history the event national title game
will air on cable on CBS yeah his TBS is
more than cable right member when Ted
Turner had Keita you know something
about cable was cool Ted Turner was
dressed in Western gear I was cable
before cable school yeah and it to me I
don't even know if if people make the
differentiation a lot anymore I think
all the games on CBS or it's on TBS what
number is it on my digs you know that's
how you get to it so uh but
huge for for our company you know I've
been there
it'll be 27 years in July that I've been
a Turner and to see the steps that we've
taken sports-wise from you know it used
to be Braves baseball and that was it
and then it's hey we got a you know with
TNT we got the NBA we got the NFL we've
got Wimbledon we've got the PGA
Championship the British Open and now to
have the championship game on TBS huge
for us very very proud moment for the
company would you be doing this if your
dad wasn't a sportscaster play-by-play
guy um
I don't know because I uh when I went to
Georgia you know my dad obviously played
baseball that's what I wanted to do so I
play my freshman year walked on reserve
first baseman 2 for 18 at the dish I
like it would you hey wait wait did
somebody laugh at Ernie over there I was
laughing cuz he knew his stats off the
top of his head it's not hard to
remember one it was part of the whole
story because I walked on as a freshman
and was told to walk off so so that went
by the board's and I was actually an
English major and I and I said you know
what I want to be I'll be a high school
baseball coach in an English teacher if
this baseball thing doesn't work out and
then I've really just tried this you
know on the con the campus radio station
w u OG in Athens and then going to games
for free and and getting to just kind of
hang out in the toy department was
pretty fun and so it just went from
there you know and your dad was the
brake play-by-play voice for a long long
time I mean Dan I grew up in the booth I
know I grew up watching him work for a
long time he worked with Milo Hamilton
folks here in Houston yeah obviously
remember the late Milo Hamilton and and
that's where I grew up around the
batting cage having Hank Aaron say how's
your little league team doing it was
great and before dad had the call of
Hanks 715 home run well he had he had
five six and seven hundred and then 714
in Cincinnati Cincinnati but Milo was
7/5 tall can't wait
that how crazy was that night in Atlanta
that you had snipers that were up on the
roof in case somebody cuz there were
death threats against Hank Aaron at how
old were you at that
it's what 16 probably I was at the game
um remember Bill Buckner trying to climb
the wall and make the catch and Tommy
house out there behind the left-field
wall making the catch uh no it was great
and I and and I was actually what was
really cool is being in the booth for to
hear my dad call 600 and 700 and it
sounds like I've lived at the ballpark I
wasn't there every night but on those on
those nights you know I'd be sitting he
be in the doing his play-by-play I'd be
a like a level up just listening and
watching him work and and it was it was
that was a very cool way to grow up I
you also went when Ted Turner owned the
Braves didn't he have Andy Messersmith
that had channel like his channel 17
yeah so that's where the Braves were
first on was channel 17 right and he had
Andy Messersmith put on the back of his
jersey his last name was going to be
channel yes number was 17 right and Ted
also managed yes a game or two um no he
you know those days and I feel from my
dad in a respect back then because the
Braves were always mathematically
eliminated before the all-star break and
and then and some of those August and
September games there was nobody in the
ballpark and my dad used to tell the
story that he's doing the game and and
he said is it well whoever was at the
plate waiting on a 2-1 pitch outside 2 &
2 and he said somebody behind the plate
turn around and said hey hold it down up
there so though those were some those
were some lean years I remember when I
went to CNN and I would go to Braves
games with Gary Miller and you could
actually sit in the Sun you I went to
left field and then we'd moved to
centerfield and then we'd moved to right
field in the same game sure you just
follow the Sun we had our own vendor
show he would sit there with us with a
beer container and we would he does that
their walk to the game goes are you
you felt cheated if you left a game back
then without
foul ball it's like how did that happen
I mean it was it was it was spark
remember when Charlie Sheen rented out
left field for an Angels game he was I
think Cecil Fielder was you know hitting
50 home runs that year and and Charlie
wanted a homerun ball so he bought left
field and I don't think he got a home
run a lot of sessile fielders oh it's
such a it's such a great game and you
know why it's because we can sit here
and tell stories ages later that still
make us laugh and still make us fondly
remember those days I mean a lot of
folks these days or think all the Braves
have were always good no that's it was
far from it what advice do you have for
people who want to do what you do oh man
I and I'm sure you get the same thing
you talk to college kids all the time or
you know is how can I get a foot in the
door it's so different now Dan you know
back when you and I were coming along it
was okay start in a small market go to
Macon Georgia make your mistakes learn
and then move up and then move up and
and there were so few other avenues
you know believed there was there were
no computers back then there was none of
that and so it was hey start small and
try to work up and maybe you'll get to
ABC CBS or NBC and those because they
were doing the major things
ESPN changed everything and that in in
those terms and then you know TBS and
TNT and USA I mean everybody kind of got
into the sports business doing things
and so I was amazed when I finally got
to Turner that the number of people who
were at ABC CBS and NBC who were banging
on the door saying oh I'd love to work
at your place but to me the foundation
hasn't changed got to be able to tell
stories you got to be able to be concise
you have to be able to write you have to
be able to communicate you have to be
able to report you know you have to be
able to talk to people and and and
realize the importance of not being
first but being right and and I think
it's so different these days and it's
and it's discouraging sometimes to see
the stories that get out there that have
no basis in fact no foundation and it's
you know and it's just somebody saying
hey remember me I'm the one who quote
broke that story why we say I blame Bob
Costas
Bob Bob made it look easy and I think
that and you know I guess we can take
some blame at SportsCenter that we had
fun so people want to do a job and if
you can have fun doing it and you love
sports then you you want to be in that
industry I find it to be the most
competitive job field in America oh
because everybody thinks they can do it
and they're this close to doing it if
only I got a break I know more than you
do see you you get that know everybody
gets that and um the thing the thing
about it we we do have we do have a good
time but there is work that goes into it
there is preparation that goes into it
just doing the show for me is the easy
part hanging with Chuck and Kenny and
Shaq that's the that's the easy part
that's the part that people look at and
say I want his job I said well that well
tell me if you're willing to do this and
this and this to be able to sit in that
chair and believe me I realized the line
is from here
into the original hermas where I had
dinner last night here in Houston the
people young guys who said I'm better
than him I could do that yeah and I
think that kind of keeps you going and I
think it kind of keeps you working hard
because you don't want this run to end
until you're ready for it to end best
story line for the final four is one uh
the game is on TBS that's the best story
know every time I say that though it's
you get money but oh yeah and they smile
back at the corporate office uh are they
watching right now at the corporate
office oh I'm sure I'm sure your boss is
watching right now I'm sure David Levy
is probably gloomily he watches every
morning yeah yeah no matter if you're on
or not sure um you know the storylines
I think if North Carolina plays its best
nobody can beat them they just do so
many things well they're so deep and but
it's kind of it what's fun is you got
one teams got the best player and Buddy
hield you got another team that's got
sort of this magic right now in
Villanova
you got the deepest team and probably
the most solid team in North Carolina
and then you got this team that goes
from first four out to final four in
Syracuse that's been surprising
everybody so I would um I guess that's I
guess that's the
storyline at this point I think I think
more will be written on Saturday of
course but I find it difficult to go
against North Carolina if they're
playing the way they have been
he's Ernie Johnson you'll see him in the
studio coverage of the Final Four and of
course the national title game from
Bug's TV on TBS tomorrow and Monday
first time in the 78 year history of the
event the national title game will air
on que el no TV CBS I where's the game
tomorrow night wait I I get this is
where you play to the crowd Ernie I'm
trying
where can you watch the game if you're
not gonna be there yes that's what I
thought like I think they said CBS I I
thought I heard CBS stop stop it's
America's most watched Network CBS yeah
it's great to see her man it's always
great to see you too Dan thanks for
having me thanks for joining us girly
and you know what try original Armas for
Tex Mex any honey you're looking for
barbecue hear that place talk right over
there by a minute Bay Park it's awesome
can we drop your name there huh can we
drop your name there oh sure yeah yeah
Ernie sent us you will get in you'll be
earned with it inside a 90 minutes you
got to like that I like that and sooner
than we normally get in Thank You Ernie
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience